欢迎收看最佛心幽默的财经节目
理财达人秀
我是李兆华
今天盘面的气氛又不一样了
昨天尾盘杀了300多点
今天是往上拉
拉了300多点
今天晚上决战大魔王
就是联准会的利率决策会议
但是今天呢
好奇妙哦
一开盘量真的好小好小
可是慢慢的盘中开始点火
似乎预告着晚上这一关过了
头过深就过
而且这段时间虽然我们看到量的比较小
我们的散户或法人朋友是比较谨慎的
但官股连续几天大买哦
一只手一直撑在这里
肯定是知道什么事情
如果说九月有魔咒
那么十月应该要光辉
这个就是历史的惯性哦
所以今天就要来好好聊聊了
量收到极致
但今天盘中有点火的话
预告着第四季
真的很值得期待
而来宾们怎么选股
各有一套逻辑
来欢迎他们
第一位是K线之神
朱家宏 朱老师
好 朱老师也要讲
他也是观察观股的动向
连续几天买了300多亿
这个手笔蛮大的
到底在户哪一些股票
这些股票确实形态不错
那今天呢
结算也结算过了
焊测的抽签
锁了快要9000亿的资金
明天全數放出來
火水是不是要到了呢
好 那如果您覺得量不夠
百元以下的好股票
今天盤面上非常亮眼
朱老師也幫您挑
進場試水溫資金不用多
好 第二位呢 是好久不見
我們統一投顧的總經理
PCB女王廖婉婷
好 婉婷到也要講
9月好像是有魔咒的
但歷年叫光輝10月
那10月就應該光輝
產業的前景繼續在發展
半导体展过了
接下来叫做PCB展
就是它的主场
今天展前就先帮我们考前猜题咯
到底上中下游
这一次展览里面会看到什么
以及现在不是涨价题材
现在要走的叫做升级题材
等一下全面帮您做点名
由哪一些女王看好的一次告诉您
好第三位呢
是我们的产业趋势专家
王建文 王博
王博也比较乐观哦他說升息的預期升息的壓力感覺上這幾天其实已经逐步的释放掉了接下来把眼光放回产业上面哦
现在进入到第四季
甚至展望明年什么东西最重要
今天有成长
明年大成长的这才是重中之重
CPU今年盘面点火哦
还有就是设备类股
明年肯定会比今年的成长率大幅拉高
所以等一下王伯委会告诉你
這兩個產業他看到哪些好股票
首先有請朱老師
你好
朱老師今天一開盤
我看我APP想說回去睡覺好了
但是後面的話盤拉起來了
今天晚上就知道升息的動向了
還有前瞻指引
還有抽籤
焊測鎖了快要9000億
明天活水會不會下來
你幫我們挑關股在戶誰
百元以下型態好的公司
那最近因為很多
有一些不確定的因素
所以大盤看起來比較連
在這邊上上下下
那國際局勢也看起來越來越亂
怎麼看這件事呢
連阿拉伯都已經開始緊張了
因為阿拉伯它只有一個上面一個下面
現在這兩邊都在出事 都在打仗
所以它的石油被卡住了
那油管又被炸了
所以我們的石油已經怎麼樣
衝過108了
近期的高點
好幾天了
那甚至還有人看到150
那就前高了 新高
看到150的話 不得了
這個衝膨就會很嚴重
好 那最近最熱門的事就是這個
幾乎很多人都在問
可不可以去抽籤
你有沒有抽
我沒有抽 我太忙了
一張抽要225萬
對 你還要有200多萬去
你可以啊 去抽
但是這個參與的人很多
所以在這裡卡了8600億
台灣人真是太有錢了
不過我今天身邊沒人抽中
真的
大家都乖乖回來上班
因為這個太低太低了
這個中千率
比中的透都差不多
好了 中到的就恭喜他了
那沒有中到你沒損失
錢又回來
整個抽籤的費用
錢回來了
你可以到股市來賺錢
對不對
所以這幾件事情
大概看起來
當然這個我們是沒有辦法去
去干預的
但是這個可以知道的
這幾天光股也互盤
盡量不要讓它跌得太多因為跌太多後面要拉的話壓力就比較大所以我們在大盤上其實各位也看得出來這個狀況
我們常常講這個多頭回檔
你看這根下影線
它是不是就拉在這裡
它為什麼要拉
因為這裡有個很重要的支撐
前面這裡有個下影線
這個下影線是大量
是近期最大量
我們這樣一直在說
所以這個大量如果跌破的話
當然這個對我們的架構來說
就不太好
所以有看到這邊有拉
昨天也是沒有破 今天再拉
就維持在這個地方不要跌下去
它只要維持住了
那利多出來的話
就像剛剛講的資金回來
聯準會的升息消息過了
這些慢慢淡化的話
它就有機會再往上去勾
所以我們這個禮拜
可能還是一個震盪盤
還要整理 什麼原因
因為我們下禮拜還有一個長假
我們下禮拜是中秋節
對耶
所以在中秋節前
應該還是一個震盪盤
那這樣中秋以後
它就變了嘛
它就會變盤
朱老師有人說
這個像一個M頭
你覺得像嗎
對 這是一個短期的
我常講看圖你要怎麼看
怎麼看
你這個怎麼會M頭
這個比這個高耶
我不會看
就失敗的學生
沒頭的話
第二個頭會比較低
原來如此
對 高的話叫多頭回答
它並沒有
這個高點比前面的高
雖然它沒有過歷史高點
但這個也是歷史次高
次高點
中秋節過
變盤的機率非常大
因為各位就知道
這個休息已經一二三四了
我們說跌三四天
就不太容易跌
所以這個地方容易止住
甚至於如果明天資金回來
可能還會有一個小的反彈
所以它還是一個
一個區間整理的一個架構
下禮拜中秋連假前
朱老師還會來
所以我們那時候可以再驗證一下
好 那最近我們剛剛看大盤
有好幾根撐在這個地方
那實際上當然大家也會感覺到
因為那個成交量不大
那表示散戶參與的很少
那為什麼又不跌呢
那叫有人在後面
有人在護盤
不過最近來說
八大光股
戶盤比較積極因為他們買了300多億4天就買了快400億那大家也看得到這個台積電一定是護盤的主角今天聯席
對 這個是主角
因為指數就看台積電來撐
那這個是題材
這個題材目前大家還是看好
需求還沒有下來
那只是短期漲多了
這邊會整理 籌碼會比較亂
那聯發科可能是最近
大家比較關注的
除了台積電就是聯發科了
對 因為相對強勢
自研晶片
它台積電我們也看到
它這個低點一直都沒有破
但這邊的高點也一直沒有過
其實它的最高點
也是它的次高點
跟我們的大盤一樣
再上去就是這個歷史高點
那在這邊整已久了
那個大盤穩住了
那最後要攻關
還是要靠台積電
那聯發科的今天走了半場的好戲
對
因為盤中他收盤最高點是站上五軍
是
那站上五軍就回後買上漲
因為這多頭啊 對不對
這個是不是多頭
這是多頭啊
那回檔如果今天站上
那他就是一個回後買上漲
是
那尾盤可能有一些賣壓
還是沒有站上
所以不行嗎
沒有站上我們就等
他前幾天這個紅K也是沒站上
是
可是它回來月線有支撐
還有現在這個上升階限
所以它還是有空間讓它修正的
並沒有破壞
它可以回到這邊漲 都可以
那我們等它確認 確認站上
那它是一個目前來說
算是結構 架構都算比較好的
如果有興趣的話
只是它價位比較高
它比台積電還貴
對 因為它超車了
但前景成長性很看好
那我們剛剛講華方店跟那個
南亞科都是空投
因為這個壓力沒過
那這個下面的支撐又跌破了
這邊跌破了
所以它現在今天是要反彈
那反彈各位也看得到
這個大阪整區
那這個都是壓嘛
所以短線上
有可能在這邊再整理一下
放量衝出去
再去挑戰它的歷史高點
好 那維穎剛剛有講
這陣子 其實談中急殺
發生什麼事呢
有人說墨西哥單掉了
真的啊 有這麼說法
有那邊掉單這樣
那我們現在做股票
可能不是每個人
資訊都這麼靈光
真的 韓中我也不知道
沒有辦法知道這麼多的資訊
可是我們就技術分析來講
前面已經告訴你有人在賣了
這個最高點有大量在賣
而且賣出來黑K
如果你是做技術面的
沒有去研究基本面或什麼
那這個是買點
所以這個地方的第二天跌破五均
是賣點
所以基本上你是獲利出場
那獲利出場後來就沒有買點了
對 它就一直跌
那這個已經跌破月線
但是就趨勢來講
它還是落頭
為什麼我們講趨勢是講
轉折高低點
所以這個低點沒有跌破
所以各位看這天
是不是會拉一個下影線
真的 對
就在那裡
因為它剛好就跌到這個
轉折的低點
那只要在這邊
不要再繼續把這個跌破
過兩天季線就上來了
那看季線可不可以撐住
那第三個它跌到這
就我們的技術分析的慣性來說
這個叫低檔
就是說你做空
你不能在這做
這個跌到低檔就容易反彈
它就容易上來
假設它沒有跌破
又上來的話
它還是多頭
這個叫回後買上漲
沒錯吧
我們平常也是這樣講的
只要你回來不要跌破前提
那回後買上漲
你站上五軍也站上越線
所以它還是一個買點
只不過這個買點上面壓力比較重
但是今天它有出量
對
今天這個量如果站上
它就有機會去挑戰
但是沒有站上它就變壓力
對不對 你如果再跌破
那這又被套牢了
又有一堆人被套牢
所以你如果對這是有興趣的
當然我剛剛講幾個條件
一定要成立
你才可以動
第一個你要站上去
站上武軍 站上月線
那第二個呢
這個如果能繼續放量那就更好
那就表示這個
我們知道了
背後可能有利多
或者高檔有賣壓
那可能這些慢慢的消化掉了
那市場還是認同
那它還是有機會去挑戰這個高點
好 因為今天盤中殺下來的時候
很多人說怎麼了
可是真的沒有聽到什麼消息
是下午才說 maybe 也許
但最好是從圖看
反而覺得紙跌點快到了
但在我們來講技術分析你聽到的消息一定是落後可是我們看技術面我不知道後面有什麼利空可是按技術來說跌破五金我就賣
按紀律走 對
這個叫紀律
後面有利空
那你就可以觀察說
這個利空對這個技術分析有沒有影響
如果它有影響它就不會上來了
它就下去了
那下去我們也不會做
今天因為成交量最近比較小半
原侠股票反而比較活潑
沒錯 那這個就叫多頭上漲
它既然上漲我們就可以追蹤
那還有一個多頭
回後上漲
回後上漲就今天
今天是好的點
那至於台塑世保來說
現在只有台塑化還比較好
其他的都趨勢都改了
有的空有的是盤整已經進到
只有這個台塑化是多頭的回檔
所以還可以等它上漲
可以等上
所以我们的目标确认了嘛
那你就在这里面找
还是好的多头可跳
我们朱老师有在8月
找到一档标股
真的很夸张
它真的是长得跟台股的长相
完全不同 连一光
8月26号到现在长得快五成
还有被动员员的小标兵信商店
9月9号长了快两成了
这支标的厉害
这支真的夸张
今天还长停
只有在这里你休息了一下
就天天长
這個比較難做
漲兩天又跌
漲一天又跌
漲一天又上影線
所以這一支股票你要做到
能夠一直報到
是比較不容易
都是等回後買
兩支趨勢不變
大家有的就尋報
那當然
雖然我們很早前就講了
但是它現在趨勢不變
所以我們還是可以說
而且也並沒有漲到太離譜
太高
我们再来看其他的低价股
这个都跟CPU有关
负财跟群众
所以刚才有讲
这个就今天就买一点
今天刚好回
今天是买一点
这是多头回档上涨
那今天有放量
那筹码当然还不错
大户一直增加
那今天是买一点
因为它在月线
昨天跌破今天站上
它是标准的今天的买点
但买的就按照纪律做
那没有买就不要追高
你不要明天拉到压力这边
你又去追
你就等下一次
群創整理好久對 這邊在整理是不是看起來不太對勁不會 這很好很好啊這很好對啊 這個在打底嘛那打底為什麼不公還有一個均線壓力還沒有劃起
季線在上面彎
這個季線還彎的
所以做這種股票其實也很簡單
你看大量的地方是不是在這
對 這個大量嘛
那這個地方跟這個大量是不是一樣的
對
所以這個地方突破就可以了
要往好處想是不是
不是 你畫一條壓力線
這叫壓力
要突破壓力
這個最高的位置
其實就是52.5
這條灰色的52.5
你這你畫一條壓力線
不管它這裡整理多久
如果你有一天收盤前
你看到紅K四頂棒突破
那這個底就做完了
那我們從這個位置也知道
如果你突破
當然就上季線
因為季線現在已經下來了
對
只要你一突破
你就上季線
而且月線是往上的
所以這個其實是一個
鎖股的好股票
你鎖在這裡
因為它這個最低點是有量的
這裡有成交量的
那最近看起來
是有人在買了
大戶有在加持
所以它沒有買很多
就是因為我剛剛講
季線還有壓
但已經有人在這裡偷偷買
買的人的規劃
應該就跟我講的一樣
它就在等那個突破
那說不定突破它會去加碼
因為它底部已經買了
那突破它就去加碼
那當然這是另外一個
所謂的操作的策略
那我剛剛講台塑化
它是回答
月線 季線
我們就等回後買上漲
那星星這支股票
就這個籌碼看還不錯
但就趨勢來講
我剛剛有講都進到盤整
因為這個是頭頭低
這邊是底底高
那你就劃好就行
我們只要把資深壓力劃好
你就知道在哪個位置你才可以買
那沒有的話你就等一等
那如果下來
當然各位也不會買
股價跌大家都會害怕
股價漲才想追
但你也要追到剛剛那個關鍵的位置
是 好不好
當然欣欣的話
也是因為現在中東很亂
然後這個航運的運價上漲
所以大家也要同步
可能關心一下運價的狀況
大概好像硬骨线都走这样
都是这样盘着
所以你如果对洋民有兴趣
那你就把它画好一样可以等这个机会好 直接非常谢谢朱謝朱老師的教學 謝謝謝謝好 基數線圖真的很奧妙剛剛朱老師說常常你是先看到圖
後面就有故事會跟上來囉
而且搞不好發展的
跟我們心中想的不一樣
像最近大家覺得好悶喔
可是卻有一隻手默默的在做支撐
剛剛幫大家檢驗了
觀股買的股票
確實大部分狀況是不錯的
而如果很害怕
資金大進場會有壓力的話
百元以下的公司
剛剛朱老師幫您畫出來了
有題材大戶進場
型態也做好的也不少喔
不妨參考看看
因為可能晚上鍋蓋拿開
明天抽籤的錢回來
台股的活水就會來囉
好廣告回來的話呢
我們的婉婷要上場了
婉婷要提醒喔
這次他去看半導體展
覺得非常有機會
光輝十月
但接下來更重要
他的主場來了
他要去看PCB展
等一下上中下游告訴您
現在要推的是升級財
不是漲價財喔
很多人常問我
現在幫小孩子
唇股還來得及嗎
我都說唇股當然要
而且越早越好
如果能夠定期定額
以年花報酬率8%來估算的話
負利累積下來
在孩子18歲的成年
都會擁有第一桶金
那以我台金專家的角度來說
我會提醒各位爸媽
我們還有一個比唇股更加
穩賺不賠的終身投資
答案就在孩子
關鍵的黃金成長期
純未來
以這個中廣核糖轉大人來說話
當然是我唯一推薦
他不但是市場上
轉大人的龍頭品牌
更有百萬家長的信任
更厲害的來了
他還有三胞胎
輕生實證
是看得到成果的品牌
這就是台灣第一位女中醫
莊淑琪博士幫曾孫三胞胎
轉大人配方的實力
第一次打得好
未來在學業職場上
就像买到富国神山台积电一样
潜力无穷
庄广和堂转大人为孩子的未来
超前部署
婉婷说他们的研究部门在开会的时候
总经说是你们产业信心不足
产业说是你们总经现在太混乱
好但不要担心
因为10月婉婷认为还是会光辉10月
对不对来请教婉婷了
因为我们都说9月有魔咒
本来以为会没事
结果看来魔咒真的来了
但是10月的話
以前的漲率是高的
現在可以期待
你現在在備戰所要去看PCB站了
去年看完有很多的收穫
所以你認為今年會搶賺的是
升級這一塊
对 好
那我们先来看一下大盘
是
因为明天一早
已经来不及
大家来不及做决定了
是
就是下好离售
下好离售
所以年清晨就要来开牌
是
然后FED到底会怎么做
嗯
好然后现在归纳就是
不升息跟升息
可是市场普遍认为会升一码
对啊
这个是FED Watch的利率图
是
好然后所以可以看得出来
9月份预期会升一码
对
已经是板上钉钉的感觉
12月在意嘛
恐怖的事
恐怖的事到明年中
总共生4嘛
这就有点可怕了
到明年中继续生
对 因为你知道上礼拜
其实那个Fight Watch只有生良嘛
对
然后后来因为周末的时候
就是战争还有游家要上去
所以它这个就变了
然后一变大家就害怕
然后周末三巨头一讲话
大家就害怕
雪上加霜
没错 其实是情绪的问题
然后以基本面来看
我们看到第四季的拉货
就是非常好
而且上周
那个OpenAI的ChairGPT6
就是那个Extra
它才告诉大家说
我算力 我卖太好了
我算力不够
所以我要暂停新户订阅
所以实际上AI的发展是好的
我们没有看到它停滞
然后厂商们会这样讲
其实我认为只是做一个提醒
好 所以今天晚上
或明天清晨
我们要看升息不升息
后面会怎么反应
如果不升息
然后这个Wash
他会后记者会讲的比较偏隔派
就是通膨可控
也是短暂性的
因为毕竟油价的上下
就像上礼拜跟这礼拜的
差异性这么大
所以他如果是短暂性的
他这个讲法
然后再加上再次的流动性
其实还没有你想象中
除了大发灾之外
10月之后就压力不会那么大了
如果是这个状态
我认为就会是利多
那就是真的就V转
大行情来了
光辉10月来了
好
那如果他有点偏鹰
他说持续我要打击通膨
当做目标
它不去讲通膨的是短暂还是长的
它只告诉你说打击通膨
那就是不明显
可是略为偏盈
所以我觉得就会比较偏向中性
可能就还是盘整
然后如果生意码
因为现在就是大家已经认为会生意码
所以生意码其实叫做符合预期
可能会利空出境
所以如果它生意码
然后讲话比较偏格
就是这个生意码只是我预防性生息
其实通膨还可控
那就没事
那我觉得也会偏多也是差不多利空出境了好 那如果生意马又偏音好好 那大家就是可能要再謹慎一點皮繃緊了是不是對 可是因為市場已經預期要升四馬了
對 所以如果是升一馬
然後後面還是維持升三馬的這個預期
其實也是在預期內
對 然後這三條線怎麼看
就藍色的話是台股指數
然後紅色是殖利率
然後黃色是油價
那今年油價上去是因為戰爭
对
好 然后油价上去
因为大家通膨预期会上升
好 所以你在交易值美债的时候
你也担心未来会升息
所以殖利率就
今年的
看起来油跟殖利率的走势
是有一点异步异趋
然后最近其实也是
可是我们会发现说
殖利率就算往上
有这个通膨预期
升息预期出来了
可是股价在行情
业绩好的时候
应该说业绩好的时候
行情也会好
就像今年第二季
其实那时候油价上去
但是台股还是涨
对 因为整个基本面更好
对 所以关键是
升息不是关键
关键是基本面够好
那所谓基本面好
它是靠AI支撑
就AI订单够强
这些AI大厂能赚得到钱
所以基本上我会觉得
行情还是比较正面的
因为订单真的很强
而且会那么多的筹资计划
就是为了明后年的营收
对 没错
所以这个刚刚其实
朱老师已经讲了比较多
所以我其实只是想要讲
就是量缩
大家会觉得说
大家害怕 所以量缩
可是其实量就是供需
也没有人卖
我一直觉得
它就是称赞一个四万五
对 所以没有破四万五
然后又量缩
缩到这个极致
刚好明天开见证账之后
我觉得一切就结束了
所以我比较倾向就是
就算下礼拜还是盘整盘
那中秋节变盘之后
光辉十月就来了
哎呦 好啊
刚好中秋节就在月底
对
好 所以接下来十月份
就是會進入到PCB站
TPCN秀
是
然後所以我今天在之前
在想說今天要來跟大家分享什麼時候
我就想到上個月半導體站
然後看完之後我還滿開心的
因為我覺得很多
晶片的發展趨勢
它會讓很多設備啦
製程啦
材料廠商
其實都會有機會
而且因為製程的難度變難
然後它的製程流程變得更長
所以會進來的人
比我想的還多
有一些東西我也有學到
好 那PCB展TBCA Show
它有可能會有新東西我現在可能不知道可是去年此時就是蠻多人一直在跟我講說晶片越來越大然後PCB會越來越半腦體化然後就因為這句話
然後讓我發現了載版會受惠
所以我現在可能理解的PCB
還是今年以來累積的
但是有可能10月看完PCB展之後
我會有一些不同的想法
但我以現在的我的認知
來跟大家分享
好然後再來就是
我先講第一個簡單的
第一個簡單的就是8月引收
因為這個是比較短線的
那短線上你會發現
上有全部創高
全部創歷史新高
對 然後有兩間公司的
除了創高以外
比我想的還要更強
第一個是富橋
富橋 優於預期
對 因為它新產能開除
然後今年不其實很缺
今年缺
但是未來不會
我每次你知道
我就會一直有那種
要一直去解釋
去解釋 這個邏輯是什麼
對 就是
不今年很缺
但是未来会慢慢的不缺
因为产能开出来
好 然后
而且它在这个供电里面
它是不是最缺的
我当初认为最缺的是铜箔
是 铜箔
不过它看起来营收比我想的好
对 然后再来就是腾辉
腾辉电子
好 铜箔基板的
对 那主要是因为
台光台药没有新产能
所以它的AI太好
然后它就把中低阶丢出来
丢出去了
好 现在受惠了
脸帽跟腾辉
因为之前驾动率是比较低的
然后瞬间受惠
它的营收跳升的幅度
就会比较强
所以这个是短线上
有时候它比我们想的更强的时候
股价会有一些反应
这短期的
可是如果我们要看长线布局
因为我自己比较喜欢看长线的东西
这种短线上的
我觉得比较难精准的抓到
好 所以长线上的话
我就会去看规格升级
因为今年是缺货
然后供需是很涨价
所以很多公司的营收
动能会非常强
可是当你知道
今年供需失衡的时候
厂商会开始扩产
所以明年产能
基本上下半年
会陆续开出之后
这个供需的压力
会没有今年这么紧
我认为重点
就会回到台光店身上
对 因为它过去
在材料领先上
一直都保有
比较强的地位
好 所以今年
它可能某些时间点
不是大家关注的重点
尤其第二季到第三季
因为它的报价长势
可能没有低阶的来得多
对 但它的规格升级
就會有優勢
然後另外南亞的部分
它雖然是過去被我們認知是中低階的公司但是因為公司它是垂直整合然后所以它在每一段都有利润的情况下它的整体利润率会提升
然后还有就是南亚希望万道超车
所以M9 M10这一块
我认为是题材性上会有机会
好然后台虹的部分就是PTFE
对我不知道它今年
因为年底才会确定
那我没有办法确定它会不会进去
可是这个材料它的材料特性非常好
所以就算今年没进去
我认为明年又会再被
拿出来讲
对
一定会每年被考虑
是
对
然后所以它现在是PTFE的领先厂商
那明年会不会因为台光台药
他们也开始切进PTFE
然后所以变成明年看后年
它的优势会
这个就要明年再看
但是我相信在展览上
可以得到一些答案
好
等于短期上面
对不对
有外衣效应
所以中低阶的反而长得
可能比这些高阶技术领先的还要多
对
可是明年一定要回来看
这些高阶技术领先的厂商
对 是
对 然后所以这就PK
之前它涨很多时候
真的耶
然后都不晓得
因为这没有获利
没有立刻拉起来
它有一段
应该是这一段
这一段排光就相对比较弱
对 然后所以当后来
我觉得它涨有点过头
再加上就是PTFE
可能没有办法那么确定
或者是不见得会
赢家通吃的时候
其实它反而这边
我觉得有点超低
对 而且材料领先
然后台光电除了
就是在原本的PCB的CCL之外
它今年底
它的载版的CCL会开出
产能会开出来
对 所以它会切进去BT的CCL
所以它会有一个新的领域
对 我觉得这个对它也是
业绩也是会有帮助
也是会加分的
然后我把金珠跟Naya放在一起
是因为Naya虽然有做CCL
但是它有做布跟铜箔
然后所以布跟铜箔
虽然明年我说不太会再涨价
可能涨价会趋缓
但是因为不容易叠价
目前AI的发展还很强
所以我认为不容易叠价
会变成它不有利润
通报有利润
CCL有利润
所以它的利润率
就会相对的通胞
因为它是垂直整合厂商
所以它的获利
还是会往上涨
而且跳的还蛮多的
那金居的部分
就是HVLP4这一块
那第四季年底
新产能开出之后
明年的获利也会有机会倍增
好 但法人为什么
那么不喜欢金居
这个我是看投信和外资
都几乎没有再大量采卖金居
我覺得是因為就是
它的數字強度
不夠強
對 技術夠好
但強度還沒有拉出來
對 那下午的部分的話
展場不會一樣
比較不會有下游出來展
是
對 所以我就把它列出來就是
重新歸納一下就是各自題材
那AI的部分的話
其實重點就是在ASIC的PCB
然後還有光模塊
或是接下來的重點
還有天上的衛星
是
好 所以像金像店真頂滑通
他們在往第四季去走
他們的訂單會從題材
開始轉向真實的數字
那最近滑通股價比較弱
是因為Apple它的銷售有點延避
拉貨有點延避
所以它營收動的一直出不來的情況下
我觉得股价比较稳
可是随着到第四季
Apple开始量产之后
然后光模块卫星开始有点贡献
那基本上我觉得第四季的动能就会转强
好 你又给电影一个圈圈
其实电影蛮多的产物朋友爱问的
我知道 所以我可以
就刚好今天趁机来讲
它其实就是今年本来大家对它的期待
就是我之前讲说第四季会有机会
因为它产能开了
然后新平台都它都有送认证
然后公司的企图性很强
可是我们其实不太确定说会不会过
然后后来看起来就是
没有过
因为他过去没有这样的经验
所以他需要多一点时间再
他需要多一点时间再去
认证
好 所以他的认证时间点
就是可能要等到下一次
是
那为什么我说忧郁期
因为单纯这个是在讨论八月营收
他八月营收
可能他毕竟有产能的
所以他去接了一些单
所以他八月营收
比我们想的来的好
那最近股价在打底
可能就等着他下一次
送认证的时间点
再来做一次梦
好 这就是希望跟失望一线之隔
对
可是在有希望的时候
我不能说它绝对没有
对 所以在一开始我们在提
就是有点N的概念
它上去是在做
有希望这件事情
那掉下来就是因为它
这一次没有过 对
好 有电影的朋友就斟酌啦
然后因为他要等下一次
可能才会重新做梦
对 然后这边是PVP设备股
然后展览的话会有设备
那通常展览除了
我们刚刚在讲的这个CCO跟材料之外
设备股跟一些化工材料
也会进来
那因为其实我觉得设备股
在未来两年大扩产的
皇朝之下
其实这四档都是很灵活的公司
大量亚太金属
穆德 长广
对 而且他们不单单只是做PCB设备
像大量也有切到板脑梯
然后像穆德
其实它有做板脑梯光学检测
对 然后载版的部分的话
是长广
它的载版设备的亚核
所以明年才能开除
它的获利成长性就会大跳升
所以這個都是可以在展前可以去關注的然後最後就是做一個小小的結論就是因為大家還蠻愛說滑通普加一直不動就是我剛剛講的營收一直出不來
因為這兩檔算是8月營收
沒有再去創高的
對
然後他們的題材事情其實都沒有變
整理就是光模塊加AI PCB
然後加iPhone的摺疊機
那滑通的部分就是光模塊加衛星
對 都沒有變
然後只是唯一就是
有時候拉貨時間點會延遲
那有可能跟厂商还没有出过
譬如说像V3
卫星V3还没有发射
那也有可能是因为缺布缺铜箔
然后导致缺C-C-C-L
然后导致大家先给AI
然后滑通的某些东西
可能就还来不及出
对大概是这样
可是数字之后都会再出来
好 所以这些在成前的
并没有看坏后面的数字
对 它们数字开出来比较慢一点
没错
大家也不妨如果有耐性的朋友
可以考虑这种还没有大喷的
对
好 非常谢谢婉婷
晚天要来仲裁
到底是总金的问题
还是产业的问题呢
当然总金要留意一件事情
假设是连续性的升息
那真的会对市场有所打击
但目前希望不要落入这样的状况
最好是晚上预防性升息的话
那市场就会欢欣鼓舞
产业没有问题
第四季的拉货动能非常强劲
但展望到明年的话
一定要记得一件事情
今年涨涨价
明年涨升级
所以现在外衣效应
可能二三線的廠商受益
但到了明年一線廠商
絕對是重中之重
剛剛的分析可以來回反覆觀看
好 等一下呢
我們廣告回來
王博要上場啦
那王博也要講
其實升息的預期
搞不好這幾天的壓力
已經慢慢的疏散了
我們依舊回到產業
什麼是今年成長
明年成長更多的呢
王博說
CPU跟半導體設備
絕對是重中之重
好 在亮縮的時候
有時候叫做黎明前的黑暗
因為大家都知道
第四季到明年
其實又會重新展開一段的行情
這個歷年的漲率都非常高
王伯已經獨家
把我們做好了研究了
到底什麼東西
今年已經成長了
明年會成長更多
這個就很重要了
你認為CPU跟設備
下個禮拜
其實除了中秋節
神山也要開技術論壇啦
對 我覺得是很有機會
因為不管是那個剛才朱老師要或者是婉婷要其實大部分都是整個操作可能你還是要回歸所謂基本面那當然朱老師在技術面上提醒大家
你可能要注意說
有哪些是剛勾上來的
形態好的
對對對
那除了所謂的FED升息之外
那當然野外的BOSS就是Enthopic
那個執行長
好
那當然我去查一下
Enthopic的大股東
那個谷歌亞馬遜
還有微軟
還有我們的
揮答 大股東
對 然後那個老黃都講話了
老黃講說
老黃是認為說
速度跟安全可以兼顧
所以我的看法是說
如果你要去AI安全
搞不好什麼
搞不好你用AI來製AI
所以你可能要更多的
設備跟算力的提升
所以我認為
我認為如果說
野外BOSS已經被什麼
被大股東給壓制了
對嘛
那當然我們就要看
所謂的聯準會接下來的表現
那至少啦 至少我們有提到說
根據過去的經驗
如果說那個升息的疑慮
恐慌越大的話
其實這些個股應該不會有表現
高科技股
對 而且這些個股可能跌的時候
那個壓力很大
可是我們看喔
這個當然是資安的啦
資安的那個cross-cry是創高
可是問題來了啊
硬體的代有也創新高
所以我的看法是說
其實從這個角度來看
似乎啦似乎
有的股票回撤
所謂長天期均線之後
似乎怎麼樣
似乎慢慢的穩住了
那如果這些是火種的話
那當然對台灣股票市場來講
就很好啦 就很好
那當然我們還是看一下
外資在台紫期的那個
好 今天結算後
對 他有減啦
整個減他的未平昌剩下
7.6萬的那個進空部位
這樣減了六七千口掉
對 減蠻多啦 減蠻多
所以大家都在想說
以前都8萬口的那個進空
大家都很緊張嘛
那現在是不是慢慢的想說
剛才那個PCB女王說
我要來幫你擦了你知道嗎
那個光輝十月你知道
然後可能就稍微解一下
那我覺得散戶也怎麼樣
也很謹慎
所以你可以發覺說
好像怎麼拉上來的時候
它的那個什麼
多空比有稍微降下來
所以我覺得這對台股來講是好的
只是說現在大家可能想說成交量
其實成交量要補不難嘛
對不對
信心回來就回來了
那當然這個我覺得高盛
高盛上修光模組需求
我覺得有點在回應台積電的技術副總因為之前在國際半導體展的時候他說滲透率會來到50%50% 2027年2027 那時候我們還討論說
怎麼算的啦 對怎麼算的啊
那時候我們看那個滲透率
今年大概就5%嘛
10倍 十倍
所以我覺得可能
不管是台積電這一部分
或者是高盛可能認為
良率跟產能都開出來
其實高盛這邊報告
其實寫得很清楚
所以我的看法是說
不管是所謂的那個2026 2027
基本上是成長嘛
而且從800G 1.6T
甚至他還跟你講說
上全聯亞全新
他還是看好
所以以目前看來
以目前看來我覺得說
其實CPU這一塊
我們還是要特別留意
而且不是沒有跌
這次剛好都有跌下來
剛好這段時間有修正了
這裡我們就來看一下
今天紅通通的一片
好 今天歡迎鼓舞
除了可能剛剛講的高盛
或者是下禮拜的
台電技術論壇
其實因為
看著很多人沒抽到
沒抽到錢可能就回到市場上
我有一個朋友抽到 好開心
真的假的
我第一次聽到有人抽到
好 那當然我們還是分成
那個老舊的CPU跟新CPU
其實我認為其實
股票有的都整理得差不多
特別是你看那個大力光跟玉基光
之前我們在這邊追蹤的時候
掌了一大段
然後後來兩個機構法人
來做一個所謂比較負面的看法
那我是覺得
壓下來之後搞不好怎麼
搞不好機會
其實如果我們只是一看
郁金光很特別
外資在買 投信在買
400張大物也在買
所以今天郁金光就一馬當煙衝上去
其實有時候我就覺得說
像大摩這篇報告我就蠻疑惑的
怎麼說
什麼叫做降頻 然後調升目標價
對 確實是如此
降頻等 可是目標價提升
那代表他之前看錯
但目標價沒有比他限價高
對 代表他之前看錯
然後這一次他怎麼樣
他想要認錯 但是又很不甘願
我不問為什麼要降頻調高目標
其實我想了半天啊
搞不懂他為什麼要這樣寫
他就認錯 然後不要不甘願
不是很好嗎
但是這一次啦
這一次如果我們仔細看的話
其實投信在最近的動作
的確在CPU這部分比較少
對 所以CPU是有回檔的
對 是有回檔
但是在千張大幅或四百張的部分
其實還是有在做一個琢磨
那我的看法是這樣
我看我們還是鎖定一些低價或低位階的
然後呢 現在怎麼
現在我剛好聽到朱老師講嘛
可能
〔此段辨識失敗，約 40:00 起〕